hey guys it's a new week and that means
it's time to talk about all the video
games that are coming out first up 343
industries grant Xbox one users the game
they've been waiting for halo 5
guardians as a new threat emerges from
the fringes of the galaxy master chief
and his Spartan squad mates blue team
disappeared faced with growing questions
over their loyalty the UNSC dispatches
Spartan Jameson Locke and his unit
fireteam Osiris to locate them and solve
the mystery of their disappearance water
solar system is overrun whose side are
you on one of the most anticipated games
of the year is yours to claim on the 27
divinity original sin Enhanced Edition
is landing on consoles this week and
publish your focus home interactive has
released a new trailer that shows off
the game's interface which has been
redesigned for PlayStation 4 and Xbox
one the split-screen multiplayer looks
functional and fun visual and audio
effects have been improved and every
single line in the game is now voiced
it's all been retooled to work with your
xbox one or ps4 controller so don't
worry about that and if you've ever been
too intimidated by the skill tree to
give this game a whirl now is the time
don't you know kevin van noord love this
game put all my RPG trust into that man
it's out on the 27th also this week we
get WWE 2k16 and it's going to feature
the largest roster in the game's history
featuring over 120 unique playable
characters nearly double 67 that were in
last year's there's no loading screens
between entrances and players have the
ability to attack other wrestlers during
their entrance so it's all game once you
enter and I know you were curious hair
physics and sweat features have been
improved ah you can really see the sweat
you're down for the count on the 27th
also because it's Halloween week you
might want a few creepy games so here's
a few options there's Albert and Otto
that's out on october 28th on pc mac and
linux also consider the nightmare
inducing bald boy that's out on the 29th
for pc and obviously you can't have a
list like this without mentioning the
game that came from the nightmares of
edmund mcmillen The Binding of Isaac
after birth that's out on the 30th
finally there's the park funcom
single-player psychological horror
experience set in an abandoned amusement
park you're following the story of a
mother named Laraine whose son has run
off it quickly becomes clear that
sinister forces are foot and you're
already in a spooky park after dark once
it's closed it's not good that child is
super dead just get out of there laraine
get out back out on the twenty-seventh
if you like scary games but you're too
afraid to play them you should check
gamespot out this week because I believe
there's going to be some house of
horrors reappearing and I think I'm
gonna stream a spooky game myself to
stay tuned for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change happy Halloween